mai zusammen wir machen heute tacos und
dieses rezept ist so richtig ich kriege
schon so einen wässrigen mund wenn ich
daran denke es einfach so lecker
knusprig ich mache hackfleisch guacamole
eine richtig leckeres salzer und wie
einfach das funktioniert das zeige ich
euch jetzt
[Musik]
ich starte jetzt direkt mit der
hackfleisch füllung dafür habe ich vorab
meine zwiebeln schön fein gehackt ich
habe euch alle ganz genau wenn andré
immer unten infobox und jetzt gebe ich
hier in meiner pfanne etwas kokosfett
das kritisch hin stark erhitzen aber das
ist desolat es riecht nach nichts und es
schmeckt auch noch nicht aber ihr könnt
ist schön heiß erhitzen und das verlange
ich auch in die infobox soll da gebe ich
jetzt gleich schon die zwiebeln mit dazu
und auch meine knoblauchzehen und
anschließend kommt das hackfleisch ich
habe innerhalb fleisch kommt es noch mit
dazu und wird schön krümelig gebraten
[Musik]
besonders
das anbraten dauert nur drei bis zehn
minuten ich habe danach auch schon
passierte tomaten dazugeben einfach
damit sie so trocken ist und die welt
merken dass das fett austritt und das
ist so ein bisschen wässrig ist er räumt
aber schön cremig und fest und daher
einfach ein bisschen speisestärke dazu
77 ist deshalb wichtig weil ihr sonst
dicke klümpchen habt und das ist dann
nicht so schön also einfach da zu sehen
die welt merken das ist richtig schön
sämig wird jetzt wohl noch die gewürze
dann nämlich kreuzkümmel das ist für
mich ein muss gebe ich direkt mit dazu
dann oregano paprikapulver und ein
bisschen chili und natürlich salz und
pfeffer
[Musik]
so die hackfleisch masse ist fertig habe
den herd ausgeschaltet das ist einfach
so stehen und kümmere mich um die salsa
dafür also das ist wirklich ein
schnelles als sap dafür habe ich hier
schön reife knackige tomaten ich habe
das vorher einmal gewaschen und geputzt
und die werde ich jetzt richtig fein
schneiden anschließend auch noch mit
zwiebel fein schneiden und eine
chilischote ich kann die so viel schlaf
vertragen aber wenn ihr mögt gibt die
ganze rein ich glaube ich ihm da nur
eine halbe heute
[Musik]
alisa bruder intro hasst
jetzt kommt die gewürze da gebe ich dazu
kreuzkümmel ein bisschen braun und
zucker das passt super zu den tomaten
natürlich salz und pfeffer und
anschließend noch olivenöl und
apfelessig
[Musik]
als nächstes machen wir die guacamole
dafür avocado einmal vom stein entfernt
und in eine schüssel geben darin könnt
ihr sie dann ganz einfach mit einer
gabel richtig schön zu matschen und dann
der stelle gebe ich auch schon knoblauch
mit dazu ihm mehr als glaube ich ich
liebe knoblauch ich habe gibt es glaube
ich fast überall dort drin aber worauf
ich definitiv verzichten werde bei der
burka mole also in ziegeln und tomaten
das mache ich sonst immer ganz gerne
aber wir haben jetzt hier schon zwiebeln
in der salza wir haben im up session
zwiebel tomaten haben wir auch und daher
belastet ist dabei da kommt gleich noch
zitronensaft mit dazu salz und pfeffer
und dann ist auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die guacamole ist fertig ich habe hier
noch die kerne drin reingesteckt denn
sie sollen helfen dabei dass die halt
ein bisschen später oxidieren also
dieses oxidieren der sonne luft führt er
dazu dass es dann zu brauen wie du nicht
mehr so schön aussieht ich habs jetzt
mal versucht ist das erste mal wir
gucken mal ob es funktioniert und meine
mutter nimmt sogar die avocado kerne
trocknet sie raspelt sieht und macht
sich da raus und tee ist auch mal voll
interessante könnte man vielleicht auch
mal versuchen so ich mache jetzt hier
noch ganz spontan eine käse soße heute
gibt es richtig food borne dafür stehe
ich hier am herd schalte den ein aber
nicht zu hoch denn jetzt gebe ich milch
und sahne in meinem kopf und wichtig ist
das ist jetzt wirklich nicht köchelt
oder hoch kocht sondern wirklich nur
erwärmen dann den jetta käse darin quasi
schmelzen lassen und ich gebe da noch
ein bisschen edler süßes paprikapulver
dazu
[Musik]
pro fressen unsere taktik bordeaux
hamann ich habe übrigens takko schalen
gekauft bekannt doch selber machen
er warte ich schon selbst und auch
erwärmt das solltest du sie alles andere
ist aber nicht die zahlen sind auch
direkt mal mit käse soße hier merkt man
kann diesen laxantien wenn man sich den
dreckig macht so viele fotos dieses
bisschen frost aber ich bin christ
wird mir richtig hell frisch witzig wird
es perfekt
haben was da drin haben saarmund tag
fleisch kammer welcher wolke sieben
dieser ist gelb
aber ich hätte ein bisschen besser
machen können ehrlich
aber ein bisschen kannst du mal
vertragen
das ist jetzt dass man wo kann ich liebe
ist liebe chor pole
richtig lecker also ich würde sagen
macht jungen die nach wenn hier gegen
geschockte 1000 zu verpassen möchte und
dann lasst ein abo wenn das nicht schon
längst getan hat heute doppelt dabei
richtig
feierlich
ich könnte mir das noch mal richtig vom
tisch und so und entlassen
dann hab noch einen schönen tag
[Musik]